Welcome to this episode of UXD.
This is the second episode
of a three-part series where
we will focus on how to make
location-based information
client simple and easy to
consume for users on the go who
are using location-based
apps that use Maps.
I'm your host, Nazmul
Idris, a developer
advocate passionate
about design and mobile.
In part one, I talked
about how important
it is to understand
the user context when
building and designing
location-based applications.
Typically, research
and planning tasks
are done on tablets and laptops.
And smartphones tend to be used
on the go for execution tasks.
And those users
using smartphones
tend to be quite busy
doing other things,
and they can be very
distracted as a result.
Not only do we have to take
the human hand into account
and optimize these interactions,
or the interaction designed
for single-handed
use, we also have
to take the user's
brain into account.
We have to make sure that
our designs minimize,
or reduce, the cognitive
load they place on the user.
To get in the
right mindset, just
picture yourself at an airport,
pulling a bag with one hand,
trying to find a place
to get coffee on the way
to your gate using
your smartphone.
Now, let's pick
apart this use case.
Let's say that you use
a location-based app
at the airport to
search for coffee shops.
And it returns too many
results that are nearby.
How do you quickly
absorb this information
and then select the right
coffee place for you?
I mean, you're not just
using this application
because you're bored
at the airport.
You want your coffee now.
So this is where managing
the user's attention
comes into play.
Their attention is a very
limited resource to begin with.
And in this context-- which
is, they're distracted,
there's a time crunch, and
they're in an airport--
you can use even less of
it than you normally can.
So to this end, don't clutter
the map with too many results.
That is, don't present
too many results
by showing too many
markers in the map view.
The user has limited attention.
They're distracted,
and so they should not
be overwhelmed with
too many results
that they will have
a hard time parsing.
You don't want to confuse
abundance with choice.
Choice is good--
abundance, not so much.
If you have different
types of markers,
make sure to give
a way for users
to understand the differences.
It's important to
give the user context
around what each type of
marker actually means.
And also, don't put too much
information on the map itself.
This makes it
difficult for the user
to touch a specific marker,
especially with thumbs.
The minimum touch
target should be 48 dps,
but also allocate some space
for padding around each marker.
And don't pack too
much information
into an info window.
The info window
shows the details
of a place represented
by a pushpin on the map.
So how do you balance the
need to display many results
with the need to consume as
little of the user's attention
as possible?
Now, allowing the
user to filter results
is a great way to give
them the information they
need without overwhelming
their divided
attention with too many results.
For example, let's say you have
a location-based travel app.
Some filtering fields might
include price, proximity,
availability, and rating.
So you might have to adapt
what these fields are based
on the type of location-based
app that you're building.
You can use the action bar
to provide them with access
to this filtering capability.
And this allows them to
slice and dice the results
by their desired fields, which
gives them choice and control.
This also frees up the
application service area
for content and allows you
to present as large of a map
as possible, which
is a good thing.
Yet another advantage
of filtering
is that it restricts
the number of markers
that are displayed on the map.
This makes it possible for a
user to actually see the map
and visually recognize
where they are
and where places on the
map are in the real world.
Big maps work hand in
hand with this as well.
Finally, reducing
the number of markers
removes the occlusion of
underlying info in the base
map, like streets, bridges,
neighborhoods and so on.
Another way to reduce clutter
and respect the user's
attention is to sort
the results by relevance
and emphasize the
most relevant ones
while deemphasizing the
less important ones.
For example, the user
searches for coffee shops
in your location-based app.
You can sort the
results by proximity,
and then highlight the
top result in a big way.
And then the next 10 results
might be clumped together
and shown with smaller markers,
so deemphasized a little bit.
And finally, the
rest of the results
might be shown with
really small markers
to really deemphasize them.
So while these results
are irrelevant,
they might be useful for
context around the search.
So a user can
deduce, for example,
that there's a lot of
shops at the location where
the results are clumped.
You can also allow the user
to provide their own criteria
for sorting as well, similar
to what you do for filtering.
The difference between
sorting and filtering
is that sorting does
not remove any results,
whereas filtering might.
So you want to use both.
So additionally, when the
user selects a result,
try using a ViewPager to
display more information
on that marker.
This is better than popping up
an info window or a dialogue
that hovers in front
of the UI and obscures
the results behind it.
In this ViewPager, you can
allow the user to cycle
through the results simply
by swiping back and forth
on the bottom of the screen.
And this makes it really easy
to navigate the sorted results.
And as a bonus, it works for
single-handed use as well.
One other way to reduce
clutter and deliver
glanceable information to the
user is to use clustering.
What's clustering?
This is where nearby
and overlapping places
are actually combined
together into a single icon
showing the number of
results contained in it
rather than drawing
one marker per result.
It's a visual cue to the user
to drill down into and get more
information on the
individual results.
And this has the added benefit
of not obscuring the base
map and the detailed information
the base map contains,
which is a good thing.
This is great for showing the
user where these results are
tightly correlated to
an actual location.
For example, if you
search for hotels
in San Francisco in a
location-based travel app,
you will see lots of
grouping of results
in North Beach, which
might signal to the user
that it's a good tourist spot.
Now, clustering does
not replace the need
for emphasizing or deemphasizing
or sorting and filtering.
All these techniques
should be used together.
And as a bonus, you can use the
Google Maps Android API utility
library in order to
implement clustering.
Finally, you can use a
variety of different marker
types, colors, and even overlays
to convey extra information
to your users at a glance.
You can use colors and
objects to convey information
about a place.
You can provide information
overlaid on the markers
themselves.
For example, in a
location-based travel app,
you can actually display
the price of hotel rooms
nearby by actually writing that
on top of the marker itself.
Now, make sure to provide
a key that the users can
use to understand what these
different colors and objects
actually mean.
That's all the
time we have today.
In the next episode,
part three, I'll
talk about the
environmental factors that
might affect the UX that
you should keep in mind when
designing and building great
location-based applications.
If you haven't already,
please be sure to join our UX
community on Google+.
It's a place where we can
continue this discussion,
and you can meet other people
who are just as passionate
at user experience as you are.
Thanks for watching and goodbye.